today i want to talk about donda
[Music]
i don't know if this video is going to
be a review per se it might just be a
story but what i do know is the story
starts back in
2013 that's when i became a kanye fan
for me it started with jesus jesus got
me into his catalogue and it also got me
into hip-hop more generally because i
was like what is this
there's music that exists that sounds
like this i saw him perform black
skinhead and new slaves on snl back then
it just opened my eyes like what have i
been missing out on so ever since 2013
he's been arguably my favorite artist
but i don't think he's above criticism
obviously he gets into a lot of antics
george bush doesn't care about black
people i'm really happy for you i'll let
you finish for 400 years that sounds
like a choice but i also don't love
every song and every album that he makes
truth be told the last time he had my
album of the year would have been 2013
with jesus but you know along came donda
in the time since i became a fan kanye's
always been one to do things differently
he's jesus infamously has no cover at
all the cover is a concept designed by
the late virgil abloh as sort of a open
casket funeral to the cd format 2016
with the life of pablo he premiered that
album at madison square garden with a
listening party and that's where he came
up with this concept of a living album
and what that means if you don't know is
it's not finished job's not finished i
don't remember the timeline back then
but you know he kept adding tracks just
slapping him on the end and of course in
2018 he produced five albums for five
different artists five weeks in a row
and for each held a listening party in
2019 we got everybody's favorite kanye
album jesus king which had a traditional
release but was a gospel album around
that same time he started performing
with his sunday service gospel for
anybody who didn't notice he also
released several albums with the sunday
service choir those are worth checking
out if you haven't
[Music]
then we get to 2021 with donda where
again we have listening parties that are
bigger than ever before and we also get
this stem player which i'm going to talk
about later he's done miracles on me
the timeline of the donda events is
worth talking about apparently there was
the first one in las vegas i know
nothing about and then came the apple
music events and the beginning of
kanye's residency in the mercedes-benz
stadium in atlanta the first listening
party was you know kanye walking around
in a red jacket and mask playing what we
thought was the album you know it opened
with donda and it ended with jail and
i've heard that kanye kind of cut things
short because he didn't get the reaction
he wanted when jail came on with jay-z
and that's because the music just wasn't
playing correctly at the stadium so no
one could hear it was jay-z and of
course the alp didn't release at that
point
so everyone said okay we're never
getting this for several weeks he's
living in the stadium in what seems like
prison conditions
he's working out he's wearing all black
two weeks after the initial donda
listening party he does another now
unfortunately i didn't get to watch this
one but i caught the end of it i was
listening to it and there were already
dramatic changes to the music and the
sequencing new songs new guest
appearances the album was evolving job's
not finished then a couple weeks after
that we get the final listening party
and this one is at soldier field in
chicago kanye brings the party home
again we have drastic changes of the
album here there's some that are very
controversial you know you have the baby
replacing jay-z on jail which is an
interesting stylistic choice and then
marilyn manson is just kind of standing
with kanye at the house of his mother me
personally i wouldn't allow marilyn
manson within 40 feet of my mom but it's
a spectacle he's built a replica of his
childhood home he lights himself on fire
at one point i believe kim kardashian is
walking around in a wedding dress it's a
lot it's an incredible event and it's
unlike pretty much anything that you
would traditionally see for an album i
mean who else but kanye would do
something so ridiculous
at long last we get the album itself
it's got no album cover at all
and as i reviewed it back when it came
out it was messy and bloated and i think
that holds up because man you're looking
at so many tracks it's an hour and 40
minutes plus and it's sequence
like somebody has no idea how to
sequence an album look am i saying that
kanye can't sequence an album no am i
saying that i can sequence it better yes
i don't know who sequenced this one but
the version that we got was very choppy
you know you had all these part two
stuck on the end and the sequencing had
evolved many different times through the
series of listening parties by the time
we got at the end it looks completely
different remember that i said jail
ended the first one and now it opens the
album the final version is missing
tracks and verses that were on previous
iterations of the album and ultimately
it is way too long but remember what i
said for life of pablo this is the
living album concept we're seeing it
play out in real time it's not just
kanye adding a few songs a week after
the album comes out we are seeing it in
rough drafts job's not finished so
that's where this comes in
so the last time around with life of
pablo we saw that it was a living album
we saw that he was tweaking it and i
personally interpreted that as make your
own version of the album you know take
what you want
but here i don't have to interpret he
gave us the album in a format that we
could make our own if you don't know
what this thing is it contains the
entire donda album it allows you to
isolate what are called stems on each
track right you've got vocals bass
melody essentially you can remix you can
loop you can do all sorts of things and
you can actually do it with any music
that you put on here
it's pretty good we can work with that
but how bold of kanye to create this
thing and give you the album and say
here you play with it you do whatever
you want so before i even got the stem
player yeah that's what i did i made my
own version of the album
the album cover i made
uses a picture taken by frankie vergara
go check him out on instagram or twitter
it's a picture taken of soldier field of
that final listening party and i think
it's a really cool shot i mean damn look
at this not only did i create my own
cover but i cut out some songs too
my version of the track list kind of
reflects the first listening party i
sequence this in a way that the tracks
flow into one another and there's a
broad narrative
[Music]
it all structure to life
i'm biased but i think my version flows
really well and if you want to check it
out i've got it on apple music and
spotify unfortunately even the version
on spotify isn't going to sound like
this because i had to make my own edits
to get it on a cd it is just too long so
for anybody watching this who didn't
like the album keep my spirit alive come
to life and 24. just listen to those
three tracks in a row and tell me what
you think
of course after i make my version he
puts out a deluxe
like we needed deluxe the trend of
deluxe albums is
it's frustrating for me it's essentially
a re-release of the album to give more
streams and they put three or four songs
on the end what kanye did is basically
that he made the album longer but he
also gave us a new sequence and the new
sequence is pretty bizarre i think a lot
of people would agree with that but he
also gave us some really good tracks
[Music]
never abandon your family if you
attended at least the first listening
party i know that track was there and
that was one of the most moving on the
album at the time but i've already made
mine and now i have to figure out a way
to get that on there life of the party
is a great song and andre's verse is
crazy unfortunately the final release of
this track does not have the incredible
drake diss so now we move into a
question that a lot of people were
asking themselves around the time of
this release
dondo or clb
there's been a lot of sparring between
these two for years now and drake of
course with his tail between his legs
after losing to pusha t has to lash out
at somebody that theoretically he could
beat i say that because if drake really
tried to me benihana is pigeon food it's
not a forgiving move head to head he and
kanye in a rap battle
that would be close problem is you can't
go head-to-head with kanye on an album
battle drake's become an artist who
doesn't really make albums the way a lot
of other artists do if you go back to
more life he styled that as a playlist i
think that was his way of telling us
guess what this is not an album i don't
do albums anymore i'm just going to give
you a ton of songs to pad your playlist
and call it my playlist the reality is
he just gave us a bloated album and he
continued to do that with every project
since so don diver clb they're both too
long we can start there they're both
pretty cohesive but they also both serve
extremely different purposes donda is a
tribute to kanye's mother he's
experiencing a lot of grief he's
processing all sorts of extreme emotions
cob is drake
being drake said that you a lesbian girl
me too hey look clb i'm not saying
there's nothing there
there's very little there for me
but
it is an album i love fast food it's
tasty but it's not fulfilling and if you
eat too much of it that's all you eat
you're probably going to die there's
obviously a place for both albums and if
you like either one great if you don't
like either one that's okay too i
personally am going to pick dondo over
clb but it doesn't have to be a
competition
[Music]
i know i got a little sidetrack there
with the rivalry discussion but at the
end of the day this is my favorite album
of the year i've got another video
coming where i list all of my favorite
albums of the year and this will be
number one you can mark that now i'm so
impressed that i got to experience a
kanye album as good as some of the last
ones i had this worry after jesus is
king that kanye was going to become the
next eminem and i don't mean that in the
sense of becoming a rap god i mean that
in the sense of making bad albums plus
my penis got an attitude but he's back
man and he gave us something really
special
and i know i'm biased because i took so
much time tinkering with the album and
making my own version and if you don't
have the patience to do that or the
interest that's okay maybe this album's
not going to resonate with you like that
but i hope something did this year
because this was a great year for music
i'm so proud that i have this platform
now that i can share thoughts with you
guys thanks for sticking around for this
video i know it's long it's certainly
not 10 seconds yeah i had to get this
off my chest i hope you guys enjoyed